I know.
Do you know
[Silence]
foreign.
Gentlemen,
gentlemen,
gentlemen.
[Silence]
Allah
I'm about to continue
in
the chapter regarding
And the various types of filth and the
subchapter regarding the ways that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
taught that these types of filth be
removed based on the type of filth and
the place the placement wherever that
is.
The third point that the author makes is
purifying
an article of clothing that has been
contaminated by
some menstrual blood, specifically
menstrual blood. And we mentioned that
goes also for postpartum blood.
I love you.
[Silence]
May Allah be pleased with her and her
father
is half sister. she's
from a different mother.
She narrates that a woman came to the
prophet sallall alaihi wasallam and
asked him
regarding if a woman has her has some
menstrual blood that gets onto her
clothing. How is she to clean it? What
is she to do?
And so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said she is to scrub it and
then ring it out with water and then
rinse it or spray it or sprinkle water
upon it and then make salah in it. And
we discussed this narration previously.
Hello.
Oh.
[Silence]
for us now.
Y the tells us that if
the after doing this process here one
time he mentions The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam mentions
that
if the person, the woman, the male,
female, right, is to scrub it with water
and then ring it out and then spray
water on it and rinse it. After this, if
there is any trace of it left, this will
not affect the person's prayer after
this process.
And not only is that according to the
principles of and that is that the
evidence the narration the original
narration of
doesn't say remove the traces of it
because if the point were for there to
be no remaining trace left then he
wouldn't say there would be no need for
him to say scrub of it and then pinch it
and and and ring it out and then
sprinkle it. He would say wash it until
it's clean.
However that happens, but he didn't say
that. He go a very specific process.
Once that process is completed,
she is not responsible to go beyond that
process. And so
we have that as an understanding
from the previous narration but we have
exactly that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam himself
mentions as much. We have a narration
here on the authority of
which has been collected by decision
that BTS.
She said, "Oh messenger of Allah, I only
have one dress. I only have one piece of
clothing. And when I have my cycle,
I wear this piece of clothing just like
I do when I don't have my cycle." And so
what am I to do? Now notice here how she
didn't say the blood gets onto it and so
on and so forth. It's understood. You
can read between the lines. This is part
of the decorum
of the time, the decorum of the Arabs,
right? And the decorum of the Muslim and
the decorum of dignified people,
right? But now
now it's all about raising awareness.
You got to raise awareness. What are you
raising awareness? You got to raise
awareness.
As long as you raise awareness, you can
say anything you want. No matter how
vile, no matter how disgusting,
no matter how sickening, but you're
raising awareness.
So, as long as you're raising awareness,
decor will be damned, right?
there was a billboard put up in New
York City a couple years ago where
this billboard was a scratch and sniff
billboard. You know, scratch and sniff.
You ever heard of the you remember in
the magazines
where they would give you a little
a little insert with
to sample a perfume or to sample a
cologne and you know you would scratch
it and then the the smell would come
out. Well, this this billboard
was
a lofty
billboard. This billboard was
to raise awareness.
Do you know what the scratch and sniff
of the billboard was?
Women's underarms
without deodorant. You walk by, you
scratch it and you can smell
what body odor smells like. And then it
says, "Raise awareness. Make make
women's hygiene normal. Make it
acceptable." You know what is this
insanity?
You've got people on the
television
talking about their menstrual cycle,
talking about their bowel movements,
talking about men and women.
But a woman specifically,
her
highest most important thing is her
dignity, her
modesty.
And so once that's gone, a huge part of
her has been compromised. But now it's a
it's raising awareness where we need to
normalize a discussion.
You know, you how we use those big
big words to do disgusting things,
right? As a society, we need to
normalize and start a dialogue about
what? About ministration. I mean, what
is this, right? This is debauchery.
And so here we have
she's asking the prophet Sam
she doesn't go into detail she says I
have my cycle I only have one dress what
should I do that was the question
what's the question is obvious but there
is decorum there is modesty there we
don't have to spell it out you see this
in the way that the Quran is worded in
the way that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam spoke.
And so the prophet sallall alaihi
wasallam said
if your cycle has concluded or if you
have reached a state of purity meaning
that the cycle has ended then wash the
place the area
where the blood is
and then pray in it. Now in the
narration of
he said scrub
and ring it out and rinse it. Here he
says
fy. He says wash it. That's all he
mentioned. Wash it. So by any means
reasonably that is the explanation of
washing. So in the science of filth when
we say wash is different than rinse or
sprinkle water. Washing is when water is
applied and then that water is removed
and then water is added after. This is
considered washing. And so he said and
then pray in it. She said, "Oh messenger
of Allah, what about if it still has
traces left after this process?" He
said, he said, "Water
is enough and any trace after washing it
with water will not affect you, will not
harm you, will not deplete your
prayer. You have done what you have been
commanded to do. Right? And so
this narration has been collected by
[Arabic recitation]